public sénat en partenariat avec l' afp
les échos radio classique présente
[Musique]
pierre gattaz le président du medef est
l'invité de l'épreuve de vérité bonsoir
monsieur gattaz
et merci d'être avec nous en ce jour d'
actualité chargée sur le plan économique
et social à ce rendez vous que vous
propose donc bien sur public sénat en
association avec les échos radio
classique et l' agence france-presse
trois grandes questions vous seront
posées au cours de cette émission la
première par jean francis pécresse dans
un instant chômage plans sociaux est ce
la rechute pour l'emploi a livré tout à
l'heure le dernier chiffre de 2016 très
mauvais a le nombre de demandeurs
d'emplois est reparti à la hausse en
décembre plus 26000 même si sur l'année
un seul chiffre a baissé deuxième
question que vous posera oriane mancini
sion macron quel programme économique a
votre préférence
enfin troisième question rexie trump est
ce que vous êtes inquiet de la défiance
grandissante vis-à-vis de l'europe
également de la mondialisation vous
répondrais là à guillaume daudin mais
d'abord monsieur gattaz une autre
question d'actualité tout de suite
une question où l'emploi est également
en cause le conseil d'administration
d'edf a donc ouvert aujourd'hui la voie
à la fermeture de la centrale de
fessenheim en acceptant la démonisation
proposée par le gouvernement
est ce que vous êtes dans le camp là des
syndicats qui sont opposés à cette
fermeture
gouhier si c'est une décision purement
politique ou philosophique je suis très
gêné par cette fermeture parce que on
sait que le nucléaire c'est un gros
investissement de la france depuis des
décennies que c'est une énergie
décarbonée propre que cette cette usine
aurait pu encore fonctionné je crois
pendant pendant quelques années jusqu'à
selon l'autorité de sûreté exactement
donc si c'est une décision politique ça
me gêne profondément si c'est une
décision rationnelle liée à une sécurité
qui pourraient être défaillante ou à des
investissements trop gros de maintenance
ce qui peut être une bonne raison en
disant il faut démanteler à son moulin
je me rallier la décision jeune maman de
deux j'ai l'impression qu'on pense que
c'est une décision politique
je pense que c'est une décision
malheureusement très politique et ça me
gêne en effet alors après je ne
connaisse pas le sud avant le dossier
pour vous donner un avis circonstancié
d'accord est ce que vous croyez à une
reconversion du site comme le dit
aujourd'hui ségolène royal qui parle
d'un choix positif pour ce qui est sûr
c'est que dans toutes les reconversions
du sinn
il faut trouver des systèmes pour
réembaucher les personnes ça peut être
dans le cas du nucléaire toute une
filière de démantèlement de sécurité de
démantèlement d' optimisation d'énergie
renouvelable tout ce qui est énergie
climat c'est développement durable sont
des filières d'avenir
donc je pense qu'en effet si vraiment la
décision et confirmer qu'elle est
rationnelle
il faut bien continuer bien évidemment
retravailler sur la sur l'emploi et
idéalement locale
si la décision est rationnel mais vous
nous avez dit que vous pensez plutôt à
une décision politique a voulu par
françois hollande ils
c'est donc un programme majeur en
période de metz avant de quitter ses
avancées bon après regardons comment
cette décision c'est très décision
évolué dans le temps on va comme
justement alors s'il ya une décision
politique pour essayer de précipiter la
fermeture vous espérer un revirement en
cas d'alternance politique moi je crois
qu'il faut regarder ce dossier encore
une fois je connais pas en profondeur il
faut regarder le coup le coût de la
maintenance pourquoi on le fait avec
exactement si on effet cette cette
filiale est trop vieille et le coût de
l'appel à projet coûterait une forte
mais le groupe a déjà été engagé il ya
eu des travaux importants dans cette
centrale de fessenheim ces dernières oui
après je ne sais pas on amène aux normes
alors d'accord il ya mise aux normes et
puis ensuite à l'exploitation par année
bon soit c'est rationnel et les voilà
soit c'est pas rationnel ci fait
politique ça me gêne on d'accord que
jean francis pécresse qui nous rejoint
le directeur de la rédaction de radio
classique
les chiffres du chômage pour le mois de
décembre seront publiés à ce soir plus
mal 6100 chômeurs en catch doria est ce
que c'est la rechute
je dirais que c'est une situation très
fragile parce que la france n'a pas fait
toutes les réformes qu'il faut faire par
contre ce que nous voyons c'est que sur
un nom le l'économie française a créé
plus de cent mille emplois ce qui est
quand même une bonne nouvelle sur la
période ça veut dire que le pacte de
responsabilité que nous avons ces cent
mille chômeurs selon l'insee de moins
sont les chômeurs de moins 180 mille
emplois en plus alors 5000 chômeurs de
moi ça veut dire qu'il ya eu la création
d'emplois quand même dont l'économie
française a recréé de l'emploi c'est ça
alors pas suffisamment puisque vous
savez que vous avez des jeunes qui
arrivent sur le marché à hauteur de 120
130 140 milles donc en effet ce n'est
pas suffisant cent mille emplois créés
par an c'est bien parce que ça montre
que dans le pacte de responsabilité
lorsqu on baisse les charges ça
fonctionne mais vous savez que pour
vraiment baisser le chômage c'est ce que
nous disons depuis des années
c'est une multi médication ou c'est
plutôt des multivitamines qu'il faut
donner à l'économie française je vais
vous donner un petit exemple quand je
demande à mes chefs d'entreprise que je
vois sur le terrain toutes les semaines
pourquoi vous crée pas d'emplois
première raison il ya ceux qui me disent
j'ai pas les marges pierre jeunet pas
les marges il faut continuer je ne peux
pas investir je ne veux pas innover je
ne peux pas exporter ça c'est la
première raison deuxième raison je
trouve ce qui tease
moi je pourrais embaucher mais j'ai peur
j'ai trop peur d'envoyer bien été aussi
le problème de la peur d'embaucher qui
reste constant chez les craintes chez
les créateurs de richesse que sont les
six entreprises troisième rejaillit très
vite et 3e troisième raison j'ai les
marges j'ai pas peur d'embaucher en
france mais c'est trop compliqué pour
étendre mon bâtiment non usines - trop
compliqué la complexité la bureaucratie
je demande à ceux qui nous gouvernent et
bien de régler les problèmes qui sont
dans leurs compétences et à dire nous
fait ce que vous dit l'environnement et
que deux salariés restants de vivarte
qui ont appris aujourd'hui qu'il y
aurait 700 emplois en moins dans le
groupe que la marque andré va être vendu
que la marque nana va être vais être
également vendus et que la halle aux
chaussures près de 200 boutiques vont
devoir fermer dans l'épreuve dans les
toutes prochaines semaines et que ce
groupe a peu auraient perçu 16 millions
d'euros
de crédit d'impôt compétitive et emploie
qu'est ce que vous leur dites mais je
leur dis si vous voulez que j'ai de
l'empathie pour eux bien évidemment
parce qu'un plan social de 52 cents de
six ans et toujours 1 à g locales et
pour ses salariés
par après jeudi à l'ensemble des
français c'est que nous devons viser le
plein emploi c'est à dire quoi ça veut
dire que nous devons faire en sorte des
sociétés puissent adapter en permanence
car le problème de vivarte
je ne connais pas le dossier par coeur
mais c'est un business model qui est en
train de bouger vous savez bien qu'il
vente des chaussures dans nos pieds et
que ce business model est en train
d'être subir la révolution numérique
avait failli côté les syndicats ces
missionnaires quoi ses actionnaires sont
mis en cause mais gourmand c'est une
société qui a été reprise avec une
création de dettes excessives et des
sanitaires qui sont accusés de se
nourrir sur sur la bête est ce que c'est
une accusation que vous entendez que ce
sont les fameux lb houde qui permet de
racheter des entreprises avec un effet
de levier sur la dette
il ya des salariés kuti ça il ya des
gens des personnes physiques qu'il ya
des faits et puis vous avez c'était tout
l'inversé
tous les excès sont à bannir je ne
connais pas la situation de ceux élevés
aux deux vertes est ce que je peux vous
dire si vous voulez que c'est qu'ils
sont dans un business model qui doivent
bouger c'est une adaptation et je crois
qu'on ait fait ça va continuer
malheureusement dans ce sens que le vrai
problème pour régler ce genre de choses
c'est que les gens puissent trouver de
lampes de l'emploi rapidement ses
considérations sur un marché du travail
où il y aurait 5 % de chômage comme en
suisse qui est à 3% ou à londres vous
rendez compte que ces gens là ce serait
pas un drame parce que ils savent que il
pourrait repas de repartir très vite la
toute dernière usine française du world
poule qui a été racheté par un italien
qui s'appelle indesit va être
délocalisée à l'ofc et en pologne
est ce que vous ne craignez pas une fois
encore que le marché européen que les
règles européennes soient mises en cause
et qu'au fond ce seul et les salariés
damien soient victimes d'une forme de
dumping européen de dumping social
moi ce que je vais vous dire c'est que
nous sommes dans un monde de
transformation la france a des atouts
exceptionnels extraordinaire dont plein
filières d'excellence dans
l'aéronautique dans la santé
dans le tourisme dans l'industrie 4.0
dans le numérique formidable donc là
l'activité nous sommes des champions
dans beaucoup de filières
il faut accepter mais pas dans le
séchage mais non mais dans ses charges
soit il aurait pu trouver alors une idée
comme à seb de mètres de l'internet de
mètres de l'électronique de changer de
est de faire du premium mais moi je ne
crois pas aux low cost fabriqué en
france ou alors il faut être très très
fort avec des hommes tomates comme mick
qui fait du low cost mais très miam low
cost avec des automates je crois dans en
france soit il faut accepter
je dirais de se transformer alors le
problème qu'on a sur amiens c'est que de
nouveaux un bassin d'emploi qui est
touché
donc nous travaillons sur le manège au
medef sur vous savez une se massent
quatre mois d'une élection majeure pour
la france nous travaillons sur des
doctrines des propositions sur en parler
plus tard et je pense que sur des
territoires il faut absolument continuer
non pas de bloquer des adaptations qui
sont nécessaires mais de recréer de
l'entrepreneuriat de long terme et la
fait pas une adaptation là c'est une
purge
mais là l'entreprise oui paul est la
maison label origine france oui alors
après de nouveaux s'ils voulaient soit
ils ont la possibilité de rebondir de
ces soit il dit c'est pas possible
j'espère qu'il a eu tout un processus
pour dire on va adapter
on va s'adapter on va il faut que l'état
puisse accompagner
écoutez vous avez bien sûr quand on peut
accompagner mais pour pour garder de
l'emploi mais après 6 mai l'ingérence de
l'état ça conduit parfois un plan social
encore plus horrible un an ou deux ans
après donc moi ce que je dis c'est qu'il
faut s'adapter en permanence il faut que
les chefs d'entreprises français et
investisseurs étrangers
et il faut surtout améliorer
l'attractivité de la france
l'attractivité de la france c'est de
faire en sorte que nos charges et baisse
et qui ait une convergence sur le plan
des charges au niveau européen et de la
fiscalité
et sur le plan social ça prendra
peut-être cinq ou dix ans mais il faut
travailler sur cette convergence
merci beaucoup merci mans series puisque
c'est maintenant oriane mancini de
public sénat qui arrive pour la deuxième
partie de l'épreuve de vérité monsieur
gattaz
[Musique]
votre question donc à notre invité très
désireux de parler des programmes des
candidats et de son propre programme
d'ailleurs eux aussi j'ai commencé
artères gattaz
bonsoir entre emmanuel macron et
françois fillon quel est celui qui a le
programme économique qui vous séduit le
plus il n'y a pas la preuve de séduction
il ya un problème de détails le prime de
françois fillon et détailler
il est pragmatique c'est le plus complet
aujourd'hui sur le plan économique je
m'exprime je ne vois pas grand chose de
la part d' emmanuel macron je vois des
quelques phrases quelques brides de
propositions mais je ne vois pas de
programme complet et pas la cohérence
donc j'attends encore de voir ces
vaqueront arrivera sur un programme
détaillé notamment sur le plan
économique alors le programme de
françois fillon il est certes détaillé
mais vous l'avez critiqué notamment sur
sa sur la suppression je n'ai pas pu
laisser un cent mille fonctionnaires
alors justement est-ce que vous
maintenez cette critique nous expliquer
ce que vous avez vu s'étaient grimés et
d'émettre des critiques sur les
problèmes il faut fondamentalement que
tous les candidats partent parle des
dépenses publiques et de la réduction
des dépenses publiques ça c'est font ça
c'est fondamental pour baisser la
fiscalité redonner des marchés l'oxygène
aux entreprises
il faut le faire nous avons plein
d'idées pour le faire et on peut le
faire avec les fonctionnaires
directement c'est ça que j'ai voulu dire
c'est que c'est très bien d'annoncer un
objectif c'est formidable il faut le
faire et bravo il l'annoncé des braves
au moins 500 morts en un an je dis pas
bravo moi ça ce mardi bravo de dire il
faut réduire les dépenses publiques leur
attrait que ça fasse en 1200 milles on
verra alors après pour réduire comme
dans nos entreprises qu'est ce que nous
faisons lorsque nous avons des datations
affaire eh bien nous le faisons avec les
fonctionnaires eux mêmes
non seuls propos sur sur cette
conférence de presse était de dire 500
mille fonctionnaires
il faut expliquer comment on fait et il
faut faire avec les fonctionnaires
pourquoi je dis ça parce que quand vous
interviewer des infirmières des médecins
dans les hôpitaux notamment ils disent
mais nous on voit plein de problèmes
plein de dysfonctionnements et on
n'arrive pas à le remonter à la
hiérarchie
nous irons de revenir sur sa proposition
d'état du tout mais pas du tout je
demande à vous n'êtes pas compris non
jeudi comme étant il faut c'est qu'on
prenne d'exécution et de méthode
quand vous êtes dans une entreprise vous
prenez une décision qu'est ce qui vous
fait vous l'expliqué cette décision de
méthode est simple un problème de
méthode
c'est un problème de méthode mais
pourquoi parce que il faut que ça passe
cette méthode il faut expliquer comment
on va fabriquer libre et mais pas de
brutalité parce que je préfère m'effacer
le conseil à françois fillon
mais c'est pas un conseil je ne serrerai
ce tonnage en fonction alors j'ai juste
vécu la loi et comrie version 1 2
janvier
qu'est ce que j'ai vu j'ai vu une loi
qui étaient allés plutôt en bon sens en
janvier qu'on a appelé la version 1
et puis j'ai vu qu'il était pas comprise
pas expliqué qu'elle était brutal là on
a eu la version de la version 3 la
version 5 à version 6 bon où il reste
presque plus rien donc moi ce que je dis
c'est que au niveau où est la france et
on a vu depuis des années si on n'a pas
de projet enthousiasmant d'abord pour le
pays pour les français une france qui
gagne c'est gagner tous les français
nous travaillons là dessus au niveau du
malaise depuis des mois et deuxièmement
c'est pour le plein emploi c'est pas
pour autre chose mais restons sur les
mêmes positions et revenir avec des
propositions mais c'est vrai dire on n'a
pas vu une île et je reviens donc je
pense que si vous voulez il faut
expliquer clairement le pourquoi des
choses le sens de ces réformes et
l'exercie place alors vos propos
monsieur gamme reste est en effet un
roger brutale vos propos ont été perçus
comme le disait oriane comme une
critique par les fillonnistes écouter
bernard accoyer
le secrétaire-général des républicains a
voulu répondre et j'appelle monsieur
gattaz à lire le programme de françois
fillon manifestement il n'a pas lu
correctement de il n'a pas compris
l'esprit
deuxièmement j'entends toujours monsieur
gattaz se plaindre de l'excès de
dépenses publiques
le candidat qui veut
la diminuer la ramener à un niveau juste
normal il le critique chez monsieur
gattaz de l'ipa bien le programme est
fait des déclarations qui me paraissent
tout à fait dépasser d'ailleurs il
s'agit pas de supprimer les
fonctionnaires je m'élève contre cette
formule c'est la réduction du nombre de
postes d'emploi public mais c'est très
bien il faut faire de la pédagogie comme
il vient de le faire dans sa dernière
phrase bravo formidable parce que
pourquoi je vais vous dire on me dit
mais c'est pas ton problème d'exécution
la méthode celle ci c'est notre problème
de ces entreprises qui sont ceux qui
souffrent quels sont ceux qui sont
victimes des tp politique lorsqu'il y à
trois millions de personnes dans la vue
des grèves dans tous les sens et salarié
peut pas venir vous désorganisé vous
enlever des points de croissance
qui c'est qui est acquis on augmente les
contraintes des obligations c'est encore
les chefs d'entreprise donc je dirais
nous sommes nous subissons parfois
malheureusement des manque
d'explications donc nous souhaitons en
effet ce programme économique de
françois fillon nous paraît détaillé de
paraître pragmatique nous paraît
courageux nous paraît courageux ce qu'il
faut juste c'est que on laisse plus
d'explications plus de pédagogie deux
mois soit payant c'est le syndrome de la
loi et comrie de janvier 2006 est ce que
je subis a expliqué le pasp expliqué ba
ça c'est plus compliqué d'accord
maintenant c'est vrai que suite à cette
déclaration pierre gattaz nous avons
envoyé un sms à françois fillon pour
s'excuser mais oui parce que si vous
voulez vous savez et rusé mais c'est pas
c'est une explication si vous voulez
c'est pour essayer d'expliquer qu'on ai
fait moi je suis juste sur la méthode
est encore une fois dans nos entreprises
que nous nous faisons du management de
toute la journée d'adaptation nous
sommes en adaptation perpétuelle dans
nos entreprises
la france a besoin d'une adaptation donc
moi ce que je dis mais très humblement
c'est que il faut le faire avec les gens
avec les français pour ça c'est montrer
une vision positive de la france à 5 10
ans on te fous de faire on a les atouts
on peut faire 2 % de croissance on peut
revenir au plein emploi et ensuite comme
on fait le partage et le fer avec les
compatriotes et sur la fonction publique
en effet je pense que encore une fois ce
n'est pas une leçon c'est une un conseil
c'est une recommandation qui vous
transporte parmi les candidats là c'est
pas une question de peur c'est une
question de cohérence de programmes
écrits alors si vous voulez moi je qui
est ciblé
dans un monde de 2016 d'une économie
ouverte globalisé moi je crois que la
croissance il faut aller la chercher
1 2 le plein emploi mais ça vous ne
l'avez dit non à l'étranger mre ont pour
mot les candidats car j'aimerais que les
candidats parlent de croissance afa a
généré j'aimerais qu'ils candidats
disent on veut aller au privé d'emploi
j'aimerais que les candidats disent les
seuls qui peuvent créer de la croissance
et de l'emploi c'est l'entreprise
l'entreprise c'est la clé de tout il
aimerait que des candidats de gauche et
de droite pour éviter de rayer des noms
est-ce que vous allez vous positionner
clairement
la france est une formule 1 vous avez
vous avez retourné la question est ce
qu'on va se positionner
je ne me poserai pas je l ai déjà dit je
ne prendrai pas position par contre je
vais continuer de regarder les
programmes économiques
je peux vous dire que le plus détaillé
aujourd'hui le plus pragmatique je suis
françois fillon accord que j'attends
beaucoup d' emmanuel macron parce que je
n'ai rien ou presque rien aujourd'hui
parce que vous attendez pas ce que vous
avez beaucoup d'espoir aussi mais parce
qu'il n'est pas encore sorti donc voilà
assis au joueur est rétro et vous avez
qu'il dit est tout à fait intéressant
mais c'est intéressant sur le sur
l'aspect vous connaissez la personnalité
mac domaine macro il ya déjà eu des gens
qui aiment les gens qui aiment moins ils
voient la presse et des questions de
personne mais sur le programme en tant
que théologien
mais non j'ai écouté c'est après vous
vous souvenez il était venu dire jamais
entreprise lors de votre mais ça c'est
manuel valls qui est venu des
entreprises
je voulais aussi non mais quand il faut
pas faux pas il faut être précis
super on parle d'une présidence de la
république française dans une situation
où la france est en train de décrocher
doucement mais sûrement et qu'il faut il
faut faire des réformes solides
rationnelle pragmatique autour de
l'économie autour d'entreprises
si on veut ré les problèmes du chômage
et un centre de d'autres choses redonner
espoir aux français
et bien c'est par l'emploi l'emploi
c'est l'entreprise donc c'est tout ce
qui parle de l'entreprise j'espère qu'il
en parle comme ça et en effet ça
fonctionnera ce qui n'en parle pas du
tout aussi c'est uniquement pour dire on
va au contraindre on va augmenter les
impôts on va augmenter les dépenses et
bien ça non je suis désolé parce que là
vous avez vous retrouvé avec un taux de
chômage immense et de ces entreprises
qui vont être complètement démotivée
justement de ces candidats à l'élection
présidentielle
vous allez recevoir pierre gattaz camp
écoutez il est prévu qu'on fasse des
matinées avec les dizaines ou la
douzaine de candidats majeurs je dirais
et ce idéalement qui auront eu leur
investiture en fait leur leur signature
il ya des parcelles et net de prévu que
je pense que ce sera à partir du 15 mars
12 mars 15 mars jusqu'au 15 avril
est ce que pour vous il ya une ligne
rouge à ne pas franchir quand vous
voulez quand vous les entendez comme
celle notamment de laisser filer les
déficits qu'on entend chez beaucoup de
candidats mais oui il faut écouter on
est arrivé trop loin c'est la sphère la
sphère publique est obèse en france et
ceux qui portent cette sphère publique
c'est les entreprises donc il faut
réduire ccrp public il faut le faire
avec
avec et beaucoup d'explications mais
quand vous en avez après vous avez autre
chose je reviens sur mes quatre et forme
vous êtes donc la fiscalité amélioré
pour inviter les marges des entreprises
genre j'appelle que la croissance il
fallait à chercher pour aller chercher
ça veut dire exporté ça veut dire
investir ça veut dire s'automatiser ça
veut dire embaucher tout ça vous avez
besoin de marge
si vous n'avez pas les marges vous
pouvez le faire et deuxième grand bloc
le social il faut faire en sorte de
déverrouiller ce marché du travail qui
est encore très anxiogène et après il
faut faire du marketing de la france car
qu'est ce que vous dit les étrangers
qu'ils soient chinois japonais
américains j'étais encore avec le ce
matin vous savez les français doucement
vous décrochez vous n'êtes pas attractif
donc il faut rendre la france attractive
pour que des jeunes talents indiens
chinois américains viennent en france
pour que les investisseurs reviennent en
france tout ça il faut réformer la
fiscalité on sait exactement ce qu'il
faut faire il marché du travail
maintenant vous avez cité les
responsables politiques qui ont dit et
j'aime l'entreprise ont françois fillon
emmanuel macron bien sûr manuel valls
encore hier soir et n'est ce pas oriane
mais pas citer benoît hamon pourtant
c'est lui qui a le vent en poupe chez
les électeurs socialistes et lui il
annonce la fin du travail il propose un
revenu universel terry lui changer dans
quelle catégorie
la catégorie des programmes absurde
absurde et idéologue pourquoi parce que
le constat qui fait s'est il n'y a plus
de croissance et on pille atouts
d'emprunt d'emplois c'est faux la
croissance encore une fois il faut aller
la chercher dans les entreprises moi
j'ai passé sept ans et s'est troué bring
sens avec une rentabilité faible en
investissant et des ingénieurs
eh ben je les fais et ben maintenant ça
va beaucoup mieux j'ai tout générer de
la croissance
pour mon entreprise est bien un pays il
faut aller générer la croissance on sait
où elle est et deuxièmement l'emploi et
bien je peux vous dire qu'on peut
descendre à 5 ou 6% de chômage pourquoi
en libérant les talents libérant les
énergies
alors après s'ils voulaient en effet
benoît hamon est beaucoup plus sûre ya
plus de travail les robots donc il veut
taxer en accès libre toute accelero non
il n'ya pas que ça il va enlever les
quarantenaires du pas de responsabilité
allons-y et puis je sais pas quand il va
faire donc c'est une économie totalement
administrées idéalement pour lui je
croise en entreprise ce sera encore
mieux donc si vous voulez là je suis
très angoissé et enfin angoissé dans le
sens sur le plan irréalisme de du
programme qui n'existe pas sur le plan
économique c'est juste des dépenses et
plus et c'est de taxer encore plus tout
ce qu'on peut alors que dans l'hexagone
robot vous seriez un gros contributeur
mlg radial mais les robots si vous
voulez il faut savoir et il faut il faut
savoir des robots là encore sous les
gens qui ont pas mis les pieds en une
entreprise qui ont géré jamais géré
d'entreprises ont des ondées concept
incroyable les robots les japonais les
allemands les suédois ont beaucoup de
robots énormément de robots ça leur
permet de faire de l'excellence
opérationnelle et donc de trouver de la
croissance de prendre des parts de
marché et bien ce sont des pays qui sont
très automatisé très robotisée qui ont
des taux de chômage faible le revenu
universel hameau mais écoutez tout tout
tout tout salaire mérite travail je
dirais que dire des sens proposé par
manuel valls qui lui fait le lien avec
le travail et l'insertion ça vous
convient mais que temporairement
on est des gens en transition entre deux
emplois bien évidemment arras se former
à retrouver un travail c'est fondamental
mais dire aux rouges opposants vous
pourriez dire oui mais le revenu décent
temporaire et je dirais bordés ce qu'il
faut c'est tendre vers le travail sert
met les gens dans le travail troisième
partie de l'émission maintenant avec
guillaume daudin de l'efs
qui nous rejoint pour vous poser une
question monsieur gattaz rien l'épreuve
de vérité avec l'efs guillaume bonsoir
bonsoir monsieur gattaz qui est une
brique citant jointe élections donald
trump
il est président depuis quelques jours
vous êtes inquiet vous du rejet
croissant grandissant contre l'union
européenne la mondialisation
oui je suis inquiet je suis inquiet
parce que la mobilisation c'est une
chance en tout cas pour la france et je
le prouve tous les jours par ma société
radiall qui exporte 90% de sa production
donc je dirais que ce recroquevillés sur
nous-mêmes c'est une très mauvaise
solution
beaucoup de filières d'excellence
française d'entreprises françaises
exportent celles qui réussissent le
mieux d'ailleurs
donc si on commence à voir un syndrome
je ferme les frontières
je le vois aux états unis et ce serait
ça pourrait donner des bonnes idées en
france non la médiation c'est
l'ouverture c'est l'opportunité de
croissance
alors après si vous voulez ce que je
reçois comme signal faible quelque part
d'ubs résister de trappes
c'est vrai les deux populations vous
avez ceux qui sont dans les métropoles
qui profite de l'exploitation de la
croissance du numérique tout va bien et
ceux qui sont dans les régions dans les
territoires qui sont souvent oubliés ou
c'est nous qui avons fait c'est votre là
moi je crois si vous voulez alors c'est
une des raisons
et je crois que vous faire attention en
france c'est pour ça que au medef nous
travaillons aussi actuellement ardemment
pour dire il faut pas qu'ils les
métropoles d'un côté avec la croissance
et puis d'état territoires désertés donc
nous cherchons les moyens pour garder de
l'emploi voulais recréer surtout parce
que les gardes et artificiellement sa
marche pas vous êtes rattraper un jour
ou l'autre par la patrouille
donc il faut il faut avec les moyens
numériques le haut débit numérique avec
le télétravail avec l'entrepreneuriat de
susciter des créations d'entreprises des
commerces qui peuvent donc dans toutes
ces régions un peu déserté en france où
il ya des taux de chômage élevés je
pense que on peut trouver des choses des
moyens kankankan donald trump et des
tweets et parle de ford general motors
et que ford du coup plus ou moins
directement suite à ses tweets décide de
garder une usine aux états unis de ne
pas la faire au mexique vous
applaudissez du coup vous parlez
l'emploi local qui reste si oui
no - après c'est le sait les états unis
et c'est la méthode de me se trompent
tant mieux s'il arrive que certaines
rames en france aussi wayne lord ekomy
par exemple arnaud montebourg il était
un peu sur cette ligne là il l'a
d'ailleurs il s'est comparé à tron nommé
temps les cons cultive le patriotisme
économique français moi je dis bravo
oui il faut le faire le problème qu'on a
c'est que c'est la méthode encore une
fois si vous pouvez faire par la
contrainte par les lois par la
réglementation et là vous êtes foutu
parce que là vous fait fuir tout le
monde
tout investisseur et vous pour le faire
part par les valeurs par l'incitation
par par le patriotisme que vous pouvez
développer ou encore une fois mafia des
donald martial ahipeaud qui règne là le
résultat l'important c'est les emplois
qui reste aux états unis oui mais ciblée
si vous recroqueviller recroqueviller
sur vous même et que vous êtes dans un
protectionnisme a exacerbé vous rendez
compte que le monde est quand même
extrêmement ouvert un avion comme boeing
elle fait de mes composants
électroniques d'ailleurs mais ils tous
les composants viennent du monde entier
donc je ne sais pas si vous voulez
peut-être que sur une usine particulière
où il ya un choix en train de se faire
bah il pousse un peu en disant ce serait
mieux vous la mettiez aux états unis bon
pourquoi pas et si ça s'il ya du syli a
en face une baisse de charge et de
fiscalité
ça peut se concevoir sur un sur un
programme économique après si vous
voulez si vous recroqueviller
complètement
eh bien je pense qu'il y aura pas
tellement une belle riche argent
comptant enfin gérer ce qui est des
impôts il ya tout un tas d'accords
commerciaux internationaux de
libre-échange qu'il est en train
d'envoyer à la cheminée il ya le le
traité de libre échange transpacifique
et l'annoncé hier que huit ans de
négociations
tombé à l'eau il ya le tti paix le
traité entre l'union européenne et les
etats unis
il veut renégocier le traité libre
échange nord américain ça ça peut
peut-être vous inquiétez jeu mais si oui
je suis inquiet par ce genre de choses
déclaration suivie de signature et c'est
très très médiatisée en effet quel monde
en veut est ce que c'est un monde où
tout le monde à se recroqueviller
je pense que la première puissance
économique au monde est un réflexe de se
recroqueviller sur sur elle même me
semble très dangereux pour l'économie du
monde
est-ce que
au final il ne fait pas la même chose
que souhaite marine le pen en france si
on peut faire un comparatif c'est à dire
le libéralisme à l'intérieur des
frontières
est-ce que c'est pas comme ça vous
l'analyse riez mais si vous lui quand
vous êtes la première puissance
économique au monde avec 300 millions ou
350 millions d'habitants bon vous vous
dites je peux me suffire à moi-même et
je crois pas en plus donc il peut avoir
un rêve de le faire comme ça et en
france en france 60 pays de 60 millions
d'habitants sixième puissance e au monde
je dirais j'espère qu'on va pas
descendre trop vite
non on ne peut pas vivre en autarcie
c'est pas possible cela sans gêner
marine le pen a dit on va faire des
droits de douane on va essayer de
recréer les industries françaises
si vous les sanctions sortons par le
haut il faut recréer industries
françaises
absolument il faut recréer des filières
d'excellence française il faut redonner
confiance à tous les ingénieurs les
chercheurs tous les salariés les
collaborateurs ils ont des projets il ya
de tout à faire dans le monde le monde
et à équiper le futur rédac on sera leur
pouvait faire à partir de france donc
libérons ses talents encore une fois en
sortant de la zone euro ou de l'euro
c'est par an je dirais en augmentant les
droits de douane à nos frontières que on
fera ça alors on a vu que vous l'avait
invité à vos débats pour le réseautage
marine le pen exactement oui comme j'ai
invité monsieur mélenchon alors je les
ai invités pour quelle raison ça
s'arrête tout juste petite question
nathalie arthaud philippe poutou
ajoutant si vous voulez qu'on aignan on
invitera encore une fois les candidats
majeurs je peux pas éviter les quinze ou
vingt candidats d'abord ce sera à
filtrer parce qu' on ouvrait les
signatures autour du 15 marches pour à
conrad et informations ensuite l'idée
c'est de questionner cesser ces
candidats marine le pen c'est un peu
nouveau pour le medef
on a vu des critiques de voeux de la
personne qui était avant vous laurence
parisot oui mais si vous voulez vous
pouvez vous verrez que vos valeurs des
valeurs de ce qu'elle a dit c'est pas un
recul des valeurs c'est de questionner
des candidats qui soit d'extrême gauche
ou d'extrême droite donc moi je fais un
parallèle entre même le pen et monsieur
mélenchon d'ailleurs les programmes
économiques lorsqu'ils existent sont
très proches on se referme son nous
mêmes on taxe beaucoup de choses on sort
de l'euro
on rajoute des contraintes dans tous les
sens on met des contreparties dans tous
les sens qu'elle veut baisser les impôts
des sociétés
j'aimerais la questionner comme
j'aimerais questionner monsieur
mélenchon sur son programme et que non
alors outre-manche
il ya le brésil qui en cours le
cataclysme qui étaient parfois non ça ne
s'est pas produit non plus c'est pas
quelque chose qui pour aller dans le
sens de marine le pen
écoutez là c'est des signaux faibles il
faut il faut prendre en compte le brésil
c'est une très mauvaise nouvelle pour
l'europe
après ce que la france pourra profiter
de places financières qui pourraient
venir à paroles espérez vous revenez sur
l'attractivité de la france il ya une
opportunité fantastique pour la france
de récupérer des filières d'excellence
mondial ii et blanc les banques
bienvenue à paris
merci pierre gattaz vidéo merci à tous
bon soir a très vite à la semaine
prochaine